ceausescu bastille en roumanie les
manifestantes envahi bucarest pendant
son discours et la ville de timisoara
s'est insurgé à berlin la porte de
brandebourg ouverte demain deuxième
journée de visite du président
mitterrand c'était à leipzig chasse à
l'homme manqué au panama noriega est
toujours en liberté
les militaires américains sont en pleine
confusion un avion de médecins sans
frontières a battu au sud-soudan quatre
morts dont trois français
il était en mission humanitaire
bonsoir pour la première fois le
dictateur ceaucescu est réellement
menacé en roumanie l'homme qui
promettait un régime modèle pour un
millénaire n'en a plus peut-être que
pour quelques jours la vague de liberté
franchi les frontières cette fois elle
secoue la roumanie cette fois le peuple
romain se révoltent les informations
sont encore très fragmentaire et
difficiles à obtenir
on sait aujourd'hui bucarest et révolté
affront suprême pour chasser ce coup les
opposants se sont manifestées au cours
d'une réunion publique à sa gloire
alors regardez c'était à midi
aujourd'hui sur la place principale de
bucarest le génie des carpates
s'exprimer commentaires gilles rabin
ce devait être la grande manifestation
de soutien c'est au csna la
manifestation qui devait retourner la
situation en sa faveur
en fait c'est la manifestation qui s'est
retourné alors que ses os et secoue
martelait encore une fois ces slogans
favoris sur l'indépendance de la
roumanie et la défense de la patrie a
siégé l'impensable incroyable est arrivé
des cris hostiles ont jailli de 7 foot
de cent mille personnes
abbas et oc secoue liberté halte à la
violence devant l'affront fait en public
au conte du quator la retransmission
télévisée en direct est interrompu
plusieurs fois par de la musique
militaire tandis que des manifestants
brûlent et des portraits du conte du
quator roms roumains quatre explosions
des coups de feu et le bruit de blad et
entre en action ont été entendues aussi
tôt dans les rues de la capitale
roumaine dont la population selon les
rares témoins prenait fait et cause pour
les manifestants il y aurait eu de
nombreux blessés et des morts
deux manifestants ont été écrasés sous
les chenilles d'un char rapporte le
correspondant de l'agencé getty ctas
tasci reste la dernière agence de presse
à pouvoir encore envoyer des
informations fiables de roumanie jamais
en 24 ans de pouvoir nikolaïs coc ce
coup n'avait été confrontée un tel défi
politique alors qu il se confirme que
certains éléments de l'armée se rallie
aux manifestants oui l'instant cette
information des diplomates britanniques
affirment avoir vu au moins huit ou neuf
cadavres à bucarest
c'est là bien le forum dernières
informations que l'on a sur ce qui s'est
passé
caresse aujourd'hui et pendant ce temps
là à timisoara là où tout avait commencé
le week-end dernier
cent cinquante mille personnes sont
descendues dans la rue la ville est
paralysée par une grève générale et
elles sont contrôlés par un comité
d'insurgés
plus surprenant l'armée n'est pas
intervenue et elle s'est même retirer de
la ville car l'ingénieur en chef de l'
usine pétrochimique avait lancé un
ultimatum
il a menacé de faire sauter tout lusine
si l'armée ne se retirait pas et en a
encore dans toutes les autres
démocraties populaires
il y a eu des manifestations de soutien
aux opposants romain roland sicard 1 est
les choses ont décidément bien change
exemple prague
à peine sorti de 40 ans de totalitarisme
les tchèques manifestent devant
l'ambassade de roumaines la répression
de chez auchan ou ne fait pas recette
et personne n'a peur de le dire
je suis bouleversé ma famille est
originaire de transylvanie et je ne
pensais pas que cela pouvait arriver
choquant pour nous qui sortons à peine
d'une situation difficile mais ce qu'il
se passe là bas est intolérable je crois
que l'onu devrait intervenir les
roumains devrait savoir que le monde
entier est avec la solidarité
internationale ça a été important pour
nous autre exemple belgrade plusieurs
milliers de manifestants là encore
devant l'ambassade de roumaines des
yougoslaves venu traiter le génie des
carpates de dracula et qui refuse de
laisser s'éteindre la lueur d'espoir
allumé à timisoara où à bucarest
manifestations également à budapest en
hongrie
concerts de klaxons marche de
protestation dans son propre camp de
l'europe de l'est
nikon a cherché ce coût ne peut
décidément plus compter sur ses anciens
amis alors georges bortoli tentant de
comprendre un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé ceausescu ce soir et sur le fil de
race du rasoir qu'est-ce qui peut
maintenant se passer
il est clair que tout repose sur
l'attitude des forces de l'ordre ou bien
elle tire dans le tas au bien elles
prennent peur et il est intéressant de
noter qu'on a vu aujourd'hui les deux
attitudes successivement effectivement
les forces de l'ordre ont tiré et paix à
d'autres moments et de plus en plus cet
après midi elles ont laissé dans la
capitale les manifestations se
développer en intervenant plus que
mollement
il faut dire que l'exemple de
l'indécision dans leur est venue très
haut puisque lorsque ce matin monsieur
le chercher ce qui se trouvait dans la
situation ridicule de convoquer un
meeting pour se faire acclamer et de se
faire siffler par une partie des
manifestants on n'a plus tout à fait
retrouvé le ceausescu intraitable celui
qui disait dans ses discours avec mépris
aux roumains mais vous mangez trop
il vous faut un régime à basses calories
il aura lieu demain je vais augmenter
vos salaires je veux
améliorez votre ravitaillement donc il y
a eu un décision jusqu'au sommet de
l'échelle et sanni manifestants dont
certainement senti alors comment vous
expliquez georges que ce régime qui a
fait régner une terreur épouvantable et
finit par craquer où je crois qu'il ya
des dizaines de raisons il d'abord que
les romains n'ont plus rien à perdre de
toute façon il y a ensuite le fait
qu'une frontière aussi fermés soit elle
n'arrête pas complètement les
télévisions et les radios et que donc
les roumains savent confusément
qu'autour de la paix leur pays
il y à des phénomènes de libéralisation
il ya le fait que la roumanie n'est pas
un pays ethniquement homogène et que
notamment la forte minorité hongroise
très bien aidé par la hongrie elle même
a souvent joué le rôle de détonateur
il y as probablement les soviétiques qui
sans trop le dire ont dû prendre contact
avec un certain nombre de leaders
communiste roumain susceptibles
d'assurer une transition pour le case où
il y avait il ya le fait que ceausescu
lui même s'est enfoncé naissent mois
n'oubliez pas que dans les années 60
ceausescu était considéré par l'ensemble
de la classe politique occidentale comme
un homme plutôt fréquentable et puis
celui qui petit à petit s'est enfoncé
dans cette espèce de paranoïa consistant
à vouloir modelé par la force l'homme
roumain pour en faire un homme comme
nice idéal il est devenu petit à petit
après infréquentable et ça aussi je
pense qu'il risque de payer
merci georges le président mitterrand en
visite officielle en allemagne de l'est
a violemment condamné le régime de
ceausescu en roumanie
nous allons y revenir mais au deuxième
jour de son voyage le fait marquant du
voyage du président mitterrand
le fait marquant est l avis à l'éthique
ville symbole de la contestation
là le président a rencontré notamment
les étudiants récit de la journée
bernard famine monsieur mitterrand fait
monter près de lui les étudiants de
l'université de leipzig qui n'ont pas
trouvé de place dans l'amphi puis comme
un nom t'éloigner qu'on n'a pas vu
depuis longtemps
le président français évoque tour à tour
ses souvenirs de guerre
les projets des dallas rda et à sa
jeunesse les questions graves du
désarmement de la réunification de
l'allemagne qui devra se faire sans
compromettre l'équilibré européen puis
monsieur mitterrand condamne la
répression sanglante aujourd'hui en
roumanie
on ne peut même pas identifié le ray
mais romain un régime idéologique
c'est un régime de pouvoir personnel
familial qui n'a aucune a raison honnête
de subsister je pense au demeurant que
les jours de ce régime dans une europe
en plein mouvement sont comptés mais à
quel prix
donc je condamne très simplement la
manière dont ce régime se comportent et
l'événement demain à la frontière des
deux allemagnes au centre de berlin ce
sera l'ouverture de la porte de
brandebourg il ya 28 ans et 4 mois
la porte symboles étaient fermés quand
le mur a été construit depuis le 10
novembre depuis que le mur a commencé à
tomber tous les allemand attendait avec
impatience que la porte de brandebourg
s'ouvre à son tour alors philippe rochot
vous êtes en direct avec nous ce soir à
la porte de brandebourg justement la
voix derrière vous philippe le président
mitterrand est encore ce soir en
allemagne de l'est demain ils sont à la
pour l'ouverture de la porte de
brandebourg
le président de la république française
ont aussi invité maria thatcher il faut
aussi invité gorbatchev socialité le
président vous organisez les puissances
alliées en finalement ici pour
l'ouverture de cet accord qui est le
symbole de l'événement
les allemands veulent rester entre les
deux présidents
rappelez-nous philippe pourquoi cette
piste et si symbolique écoutez cette
symbole de verdad 200 ans exactement là
fortement de vous re a vu défiler les
troupes prussiennes et troupes
napoléoniennes des troupes aériennes et
à la guerre les forces alliées pour les
allemands est ce que vous croyez si
libre que demain il y aura autant monde
autour de l'apport d'un côté comme de
l'autre autant de monde que le fameux 10
novembre quand la porte est ouverte
depuis quinze jours il ya eu une
cinquantaine de points de passage qui
ont été ouverts aux frontières entre
berlin et puis également à la frontière
interallemande et à chaque fois il y
avait beaucoup de monde mais là c'est ce
que croit intéressant à guetter ce sont
des manifestations pour la réunification
et contre la réunification également y
auront certainement demain s'il a besoin
de moi une sorte de test
merci philippe et bien sûr vous nous
ferez vivre cet événement demain dans
nos différentes éditions
l'intervention militaire des américains
au panama ce n'est pas un sans succès la
situation est confuse noriega n'a
toujours pas été capturés alors que
c'était le but fixé par washington
premier bilan donné par les militaires
américains 19 morts et 117 blessés dans
leurs rangs
il aurait fait 1500 prisonniers panaméen
pour les partisans de noriega qui
veulent s'opposer à la mainmise
américaine sur leur pays
une reddition du dictateur est
inconcevable mais d'abord le point à
panama city michel mompontet ces camions
de l'hôtel marriott réquisitionnés par
les gi's de la 82e division sont
destinés à évacuer les civils américains
qui y sont réfugiés depuis 24 heures
la zone est tenu par les troupes de
noriega les risques sont grands
toute l'opération se fera sous la
protection des fusils d'assaut m-16
américain les gi's sont prêts à faire
feu sur tout ce qui bouge placée dans la
ligne de mire l'équipe de télévision est
un instant prises pour l'ennemi il est
impératif alors de s'identifier reculer
reculer nous sommes avec une américaine
nous sommes américains
nous sommes avec une américaine fait
quelque chose
elle est juste à côté après 24 heures
cachées sous les fourrés elle réussit
enfin à fuir dans une jeep blindée de
mieux s'armer l'évacuation des civils
américains
c'était la première des trois missions
attribuées à ces vingt-deux mille cinq
cents hommes envoyés au panama la
deuxième démission des gi's américains
était de libérer les prisonniers
politiques mais en ouvrant les prisons
du panama ce sont surtout des
prisonniers de droit commun qui sont
sortis scènes de pillages dans le centre
de la capitale les combats militaires
outils six essais et on parle d'une
véritable pègre contrôlons ce soir la
rue magasin dévasté règlement de comptes
les hôpitaux de panama city sont
débordés on parle ici d'une centaine de
morts de milliers de blessés depuis la
tacc américaine les sirènes des
ambulances n'ont pas cessé le troisième
des objectifs de l'attak américaine
était bien sûr la capture de noriega
il est ce soir introuvable mais pour les
américains il sera désormais difficile
de le capturer
et pour cause c'est eux mêmes qui l'ont
enseigné il y a quelques années les
techniques difficiles de la vie
clandestine
la presse américaine est souvent vous le
savez critique à l'égard du président
bush mais pour une fois elle est unanime
pour soutenir l'intervention militaire
l'opinion publique est à l'unisson
jacquat bouchard à washington 300
protestataires dans les rues de san
francisco la seule manifestation connue
aux états unis de soutien à noriega
contre l'intervention au panama à
washington au contraire
l'appui à george bush est
inconditionnelle quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle j'ai dis bravo
il était plus que temps d'agir c'est
bien maintenant il faudrait attaquer le
nicaragua ray j'avais une réaction comme
j'imagine tous les américains que le
président avait raison mais en même
temps gérer notre côté plus
un big que c'est pas tout à fait de
moyens de traiter avec les pays de
l'amérique latine
les forces américaines écrase d'armé du
panama le titre barre toute la une du
washington post l'un des quotidiens
influent aux etats-unis huit pages
consacrées à l'événement
comme l'ensemble de la presse le post
soutient l'intervention militaire connu
pour ses positions libérales le new york
times annonce la couleur dans un de ses
sous titres pourquoi l'invasion était
justifiée vous pouvez le constater la
presse comme l'opinion américaine n'ont
pas d'état d'âme et un responsable un
peu goguenard
face aux réactions hostiles de
l'étranger me faisait la remarque
suivante
autrefois on nous reprochait de
pratiquer la politique du gros bâton
pour installer ou maintenir des
dictateurs au pouvoir et aujourd'hui on
viendrait nous accuser d'impérialisme
parce que nous chassons un dictateur
trois français de médecins sans
frontières ainsi qu'un technicien
soudanais ont été tuées au sud soudan ce
matin l'avion des quatre hommes a été
abattu il travaillait dans une mission à
à wil une petite localité où affluent
les réfugiés qui sont chassés par les
combats dans la région
claude crespo pour le renfermé c'était
la première mission ce logisticien avait
à charge tous les problèmes de transport
de matériel et des vivres pour yvon
féllo le pilote c'était aussi la
première fois sur cette région du sud
soudan dans l'avion un appareil
identique à celui ci qui les ramenait à
khartoum il y avait encore un autre
français jean paul bescond médecin et un
technicien soudanais et le drame s'est
déroulé ce matin l'avion d'aviation sans
frontières qui volait pour faire des
rotations régulières entre les
différentes missions que médecins sans
frontières dans le soudan a été abattu
quelques instants après le décollage à
partir d'un oui celui-là cette année
dans le cadre de la grande reprise des
opérations de secours sur le soudan mais
saf avaient repris ses activités
ah oui et nous avions une équipe en
permanence à wind cinq personnes depuis
février
avec toutes les autorisations de vol
toutes les autorisations les
reconnaissances sont autre certitude
l'avion n'a pas pu non plus être
confondu avec un appareil militaire
même ici dans cette région ce combat de
forces gouvernementales et rebelles
ah oui msf ne s'occupait que d'un
hôpital pour réfugiés et d'un centre de
nutrition
une grève qui devient très impopulaire
c'est celle des nmpp
la cgt qui a le monopole absolu dans
cette entreprise continue par sa seule
volonté de paralyser toute la presse
française
on espérait un accord ce soir on n'y est
pas encore françoise joly ce face à face
sans résultat aura duré trois heures
d'un côté la direction pour être accordé
une prime de modernisation 6000 francs
répartis sur 14 mois
de l'autre la cgt qui réclame des
garanties en matière d'emploi et de
qualification et pourtant
premier signe de détente dans ce conflit
le quotidien le monde a pu être
distribués cet après-midi les piquets de
grève ont été levées c'était d'ailleurs
la condition sinequanone que poser la
direction à la reprise du dialogue
un geste de bonne volonté de la part des
grévistes après la pression très forte
de ces derniers jours
opération coup de poing de la cgt
bagarre manifestation
les autres syndicats et les
professionnels dénoncent le monopole
syndical de la cgt les patrons de presse
envisage même de créer une nouvelle
structure de distribution car ce conflit
coûte très cher aux journaux et aux
distributeurs
ils sont 36 milles et créa la faillite
ce soir les négociations vont reprendre
si elles devaient aboutir
elle mettrait fin au 14e conflit depuis
le début de l'année dans les nems pp oui
j'ajoute que jean auroux l'ancien
ministre socialiste du travail a estimé
tout à l'heure que le monopole de la cgt
oleme pépé était inacceptable
le quotidien le monde de son côté
dénonce dans son édition d'aujourd'hui
les pratiques inadmissibles des
grévistes des nmpp et dans un éditorial
il demande aux pouvoirs publics
d'assurer la liberté de la distribution
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
de la journée en bref avec anne consigny
poursuite des recherches dans la région
de castelviel en gironde où un
agriculteur et sa famille ont été
massacrés le père la mère la fille et
son enfant ont été retrouvés hier dans
leur ferme le crâne défoncé le père et
l'autre grand père de l'enfant
interpellée cet après-midi ont été
relâchés après avoir fourni un alibi
le record de durée en caisson de
confinement battu par un plongeur de la
comex arnaud denéchaud de ferrals a
passé soixante douze jours dans ce
caisson nommé hydra 9 à moins 300 mètres
avant lui trois autres plongeurs avaient
abandonné accord administration
syndicats de pharmaciens sur le prix des
médicaments à partir du 15 février plus
un médicament sera cher - la marge
réalisée par le pharmacien et sera
importante
fille
un accord sur la fusion des entreprises
mis au point aujourd'hui à bruxelles par
les ministres des 12 chargé des
questions européennes toute fusion
portant sur un chiffre d'affaires global
de plus de 35 milliards de francs devra
être examiné par la commission
européenne
des dizaines de milliers d'islamistes
manifestent aujourd'hui devant
l'assemblée nationale à alger
manifestations en réponse un
rassemblement d'intellectuels organisée
jeudi dernier au même endroit contre
l'intégrisme et l'intolérance
forte hausse à la bourse de paris où
l'indicé cac 40 progresse de 1,31 pour
cent le dollar s'établit à 5 francs 86
france 91 35 le cours officiel
voilà nous revenons maintenant sur les
événements de roumanie où vous savez le
régime du dictateur ceausescu est en
train de vaciller
avec ces deux précisions d'abord je
viens de l'apprendre avec mon ordinateur
les selon une agence yougoslave le bilan
de ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui à
bucarest des affrontements serait de 20
morts et de dizaines de blessés c'est
une agence yougoslave qui était sur
place qu'il affirme ce soir
et puis je vous propose maintenant
d'écouter un témoignage un témoignage
que nous venons de recevoir par
téléphone il s'agit d'un réfugié roumain
qui vient d'arriver en hongrie il venait
de roumanie et il donne des précisions
sur ce qui s'est passé à timisoara
écoutez c'est qu'il ya eu des mains à
bucarest selon les informations me sers
des affaires étrangères il ya eu des
dizaines de milliers de personnes dans
la rue à bucarest répète c'était pas du
tout des multitudes discipliné a été
pour la première fois été ni dans les
discussions patinent un difficile combat
quittent ce matin au poste
personne ne sait quand la caméra bien il
ya eu deux morts on peut dire catherine
michaud il ya eu un véritable massacre
comme chez sera couvrir ses crimes donné
lundi tous les cada en 2000 et le genre
soit brûlé voilà pour ce témoignage
exclusif que nous venons d'obtenir en
téléphonant donc à se réfugier roumain
qui venait d'arriver de roumanie et qui
arrivait donc en hongrie revenons au
cours de l'actualité avec la france
les divers passe les restos du coeur
sont toujours pleins comme quoi
l'initiative de coluche 185 était
vraiment utile huit cent cinquante
restaurants du coeur ont ouvert pour la
cinquième année consécutive leurs
clients des dizaines de milliers de
déshérités c'est en france agnès poirier
ils sont venus chercher un peu de
nourriture un peu de chaleur comme tous
les ans la même détresse
grâce aux restos du coeur l'hiver sera
un peu moins rude
pourquoi vous êtes venus là ce matin
parce que j'ai deux enfants en bas âge
que je ne travaille pas pour le moment
et que vous
comme permet de
que subvenir à mes besoins aliments
en attendant la nourriture doit aller à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
alors on vérifie leurs ressources en
général le rmi le montant des
allocations familiales ou le chômage du
sucre du lait des endives des steaks
hachés des bananes de la nourriture qui
arrive tout droit des excédents de la
cee des stocks des grandes surfaces ou
qui a été achetée grâce au dos on a
toujours besoin des donateurs parce que
sans eux on n'existerait pas du tout et
puis on a besoin de bénévoles parce que
c'est aussi qui permettent de faire
fonctionner les restaurants du coeur
l'argent donné par les donateurs est
ensuite répartie intégralement ou
presque à l'aide alimentaire qui sont à
moins de 4% très généreux donner à
manger à ceux qui ont faim ils sont
nombreux l'hiver dernier les restos du
coeur ont distribué 25 millions de repas
noël approche alors cette question étant
sûr que le père noël reçoit réellement
toutes les lettres qui lui sont adressés
la réponse vous allez le voir va
rassurer les enfants et les adultes car
la réponse est oui car les ptt en effet
font en sorte de lui acheminer toutes
les lettres et pour cela les ptt on a
installé un bureau spécial à libourne
un bureau qui déborde de travail vincent
gerard christian leroux révélations
exclusives
ouah c'est pour toi toutes ces lettres
père noël ça doit être donné un paquet
de boulot di donc c'est énorme c'est si
c'est plus de 500 me répond ce que nous
allons faire
ah bah oui mais c'est normal tu es
vachement connu tellement connu qu'on
peut écrire n'importe quelle adresse
quatrième nuage à gauche premiers nuages
à droite dans le ciel près de l'étoile
polaire
et tout ça ça arrive quand même chez toi
mais alors dit don qui tu es toi tel
père noël non je ne suis pas le père
noël jeu je suis secrétaire le
secrétaire principal du père noël
ça bosse dur en ce moment heureusement
que t'es pas tout seul
comment t'as 40 secrétaire as-tu tempête
pas elles sont plutôt mignonne
d'ailleurs dis donc toi tu cherches pas
lui ressembler au père noël tu ferais
mieux de lire toutes ses lettres
c'est ça ton boulot non le travail de
lecture c'est le travail du père noël
c'est fin c'est pas moi tu va offrir des
cadeaux aux enfants et pas de problème
ah bon tu renvoies juste un petit mot
remarques depuis 27 ans que ça dure
rien à dire il est classique mais bien
pourtant il ya un truc qui m'échappe pu
répondre aux lettres mais tu oublies les
cadeaux tu mets le traîneau avant les
rênes heureusement quand il fait penser
aux cadeaux
on essaye même de t'acheter
souvent le père noël pas nous nous avons
défraya me disent qu'ils ont fait c'est
un voilier par des petites mains de
bretagne ils sont futés les petits
français
il ya plein d'école qui font des
commandes groupées tête à cause des prix
les petits étrangers eux ils savent pas
encore mais ils écrivent quand même et 2
partout de l'europe de l'est que nous
recevons le pistent courrier l'allemagne
de l'est priorité oui ben c'est pas ça
je t'écris j'espère que ton traîneau est
pas cassé et que les rênes sont enfants
pour que tu voyages jusqu'à là bas
tranquille mais lorsque je savais pas
c'est qu'il ya pas que les enfants qui
s'écrit père noël il y à des personnes
seules qui écrivent au père noël et
elles n'ont qu'une lettre dans toute
l'année c'est la réponse qui est fait
par le père mais ça c'est gentil père
noël j'étais sûr que c'était un mec bien
le cinéma maintenant connaissez-vous
bandit ni non et bien c'est que vous ne
connaissez pas john fante et bandini
c'est le héros de l'écrivain john fante
t1 américain mort il ya peu de temps
c'est d'ailleurs une histoire très
curieuse car fentes et qui a écrit des
romans magnifique et est tombé dans
l'oubli aux états unis et il travaillait
comme scénariste simplement
et puis il y a trois quatre ans les
français l'ont redécouvert puis ensuite
les américains
il est même devenu très à la mode et
maintenant on veut adapter tous ses
romans le premier film sort
il s'appelle bandini nicole cornu logo
arturo bandini c'est le vrai nom de john
fante et écrivain méconnu à sa mort et
dont les cinéastes se disputent
maintenant les livres autobiographiques
bouleversant de vérité vendredi me
raconte son enfance pauvre dans le
colorado et les rapports passionnels
entre son père sa mère et une belle et
riche intruse il avait 29 ans quand il
écrivit slip auteurs
29 ans c'est aussi l'âge de dominique de
rudare admirateurs et adaptateurs
fidèles de son leurre qui a recréé
l'univers du jeune arthur au
italo-américain plus nous offre et
escota ça va mal finir
wii fit ou la feria que blasko roaming
et cette simplicité et qu'il a dans son
écriture
j'ai essayé de le garder dans un film
donc c'est un film qui est qui est mise
en scène très simplement tout est un
service service l'histoire et c'est
aussi pour ça que les couleurs là dans
le film sont tellement monochromatique
on voudrait raconter cette histoire
comme si c'était ta mémoire de quelqu'un
qui a vu les choses tu peux que les
mensonges qui est toujours là aussi dans
la mémoire
arturo se souvient de sa famille
d'émigrés le père qu'onéreux les frères
ennemis et la mer indulgente sort et on
pousse une grosse pêche changer le nom
des nominés ce faire il se souvient
aussi de l'autre dame ailleurs familles
chinoises
chimay ce seuil
soit
cheseaux ici à tora simplicité et
émotion humour non john fante et n'a pas
été trahi
tiercé quarté c'était à vincennes voici
les résultats les rapports 8 13 h 16
1817 francs 50 c'est pas mal pour un
tiercé dans l'ordre
3600 sont 350 c'est dans le désordre le
quarté pour 5 francs toujours 8 13 h 17
et comme c'est trop long je vous laisse
lire les rapports à propos de chiffres
une petite rectification nous avons fait
une erreur tout à l'heure le dollar nous
l'avons donné à 6 francs 90 il était
bien sûr à 590 les spécialistes auront
rectifié d'eux mêmes la météo c'est
laurent cabrol tout de suite le dernier
journal henri sannier vers 23h30 et à 7
heures demain matin premier journal de
la rédaction
rachid arhab bonne soirée à demain 20
heures